hello and welcome to footnotes I'm here
to recap the most ravishing language and
ideas from the last week of Wired first
up today if a butterfly flaps its wings
in Peru are you in danger even if you're
on generally good terms with butterflies
it's the butterfly effect it was
referenced in a wired Enterprise story
on a network error in Indonesia bringing
down some of Google in the greatest 27
minutes to ever happen to Bing this
butterfly effect refers to a seemingly
tiny event having a massive impact in a
larger system the term was coined in the
1950s by meteorologist Edward Lorenz who
while running weather models didn't
realize the computer had rounded off one
of his inputs very slightly changing it
and things went cray-cray resulting in
completely unexpected weather models not
like raining frogs unexpected but still
pretty unexpected subsequently Lorenz
came up with an analogy that goes
something like this a butterfly flaps
its wings and that minut air current
changes the local weather varies
slightly which in turn changes the
weather on a global scale this then
causes a tornado in Kansas which picks
up a house and deposits it on a witch
simple stuff really such snowballing
events are staples in the Time
Traveler's onra in which a very small
change in the past can totally ruin all
of your pictures in the future so next
time you see a butterfly don't look at
it funny one day it just might drop a
house on you next up if birds so naive
it had no idea that being a defenseless
animal around hungry sailors was a poor
life choice it's the dodo and it
appeared in not one but two stories last
week in a wired science gallery on
skulls and Link post on an iPad case
that is for some reason named after the
bird the dodo is the most famous of the
many recently extinct species having
become synonymous with obsolescence just
like year old apple products it lived on
the tiny island of Mauritius east of
Madagascar had it been able to talk like
the animals of Madagascar it might have
been able to negotiate for its survival
first described by Dutch sailors around
photos had no fear of humans on top of
being unable to fly on top of being
avowed pacifist the dodo was wiped out
in only 60 years by overhunting and by
invasive and domestic species brought by
the humans pigs in particular were wild
for their eggs but alas the Dodos didn't
have slingshots to fight back with oddly
enough we don't have a good idea of what
color the Dodos were because first-hand
accounts were inconsistent for all we
know that could have had lucrative
sponsorships so what happens when a dodo
flaps it's useless wings hurricanes
tornadoes it's nothing actually because
all the Dodos are dead